[Music]
in a special year-end edition of the
dish this morning Eleven Madison Park
and the talent behind it the venerated
New York restaurant has earned just
about every possible honor three stars
from the Michelin Guide four stars from
the New York Times and in 2017 the
influential guide world's 50 best named
it the best restaurant in the world the
pair behind Eleven Madison Park has
slowly been expanding their reach that
includes a much less formal affair a
seasonal pop up in Colorado high atop
the Rocky Mountains in Aspen Colorado
chef Daniel home and his partner will
Ghidorah have taken their elevated
cuisine on a winter break part of the
menu this evening trout Meuniere beef
stroganoff herb crusted lamb the dishes
and the ten outdoor tables tucked inside
yurts
are a nod to whose Swiss roots for the
first time in my life I get to do the
food that I grew up with has it been fun
to be able to create this menu so fun
fun is something who mingi Dora have
brought to fine dining even at their
Cathedral Eleven Madison Park in New
York know their chef-driven restaurants
who invariably do its best for the food
there's restauranteur driven restaurants
that do its best for the service but we
like to think that we end up doing
what's best for the restaurant as a
whole Ghidorah oversees a front of house
staff of 60 who meticulously follow the
details of a 110 page training guide and
they created the unique position the
dreamweaver who caters to a tables every
need and more there was a table sitting
over there they were here on their way
to the airport going back to Europe and
we overheard them saying what a great
trip they had but they were lamenting
the fact that they never had a New York
City hot dog and so I ran out to the
hotdog cart in front of the restaurant
bought a hotdog and brought it back to
him in the kitchen
I said Daniel can we serve this to them
as their next course your response was
what
but understandably so you know these
dishes were about to have it takes three
days to produce some of the right but he
trusted me enough to know that there was
probably good reason for it
and so he cut the hotdogs in perfect
pieces and did a swoosh of mustard and a
swish of ketchup in a canal of
sauerkraut and we brought it to them and
said hey we wanted to make sure you
didn't miss out on that
and that's the beauty of what we get to
do and you see the looks on someone's
face when you do that it is that kind of
service along with blooms craftsmanship
in the kitchen that has made Eleven
Madison Park a destination so you have
to duck that's our signature is sort of
a signature recipe every dish in the
menu changes every season the only dish
that never changes is the duck at 40 to
whom is considered one of the best chefs
in the world
I do sometimes feel that kind of on top
of the world for sure and for some
people it might seem like this happened
overnight and it didn't in fact growing
up in Switzerland whom had no particular
interest in food but his mother did
insisting that they buy their produce
from local farms and sometimes that was
really annoying
this one day she had all these
vegetables covered in in mud you know
because of the rain and she said oh can
you wash this for me and I was washing
it like four times five times and then I
said why can we not buy like the lettuce
in the grocery store like everyone else
and she took out a leave and she's like
try this and I remembered the salad
being so crunchy and so sweet and juicy
almost and she looked at me and she's
like this is why and that's a lesson
that I never forgot when he was just 14
years old whom left home to pursue a
professional cycling career and got a
job in a kitchen to make extra money I
was a prep cook but I had an amazing
chef and he's like I know you're here
just for a paycheck but let me teach you
how to butcher chick and how to make a
soup to make good consomme how to make a
souffle
all these things and in the beginning I
was like you don't need to show me that
I'm I'm good I'm a racer it's okay race
they said no I'm gonna teach you a
serious cycling accident when he was 22
made him reevaluate his career path whom
embraced his love of cooking and found
work in the industry in Switzerland when
he got an opportunity to interview for a
position at Kempton place in San
Francisco did you hesitate for sure I
mean at that point I did not speak
English I've never been outside of
Europe all I knew at that point about
America was definitely not the food that
I thought myself as a chef I'm afraid
you know I was open enough to come for
an interview and then I was in San
Francisco and I was brought around to
the markets and the city and Napa Valley
and my mind was blown away
who was wooed to Eleven Madison Park by
legendary restaurant Tour Danny Meyer
where he teamed up with Gaddar Oh
in 2010 the pair were invited to the
awards for the 50 best restaurants in
the world
we barely sat down the list starts and
they said and number 50 in the world new
entry from America Eleven Madison Park
number 50 so that night we felt
extremely disappointed even though it
was a huge honor he was an owner but we
came in very last right we went back to
the hotel we bought a bottle of whiskey
honestly and we sat out there all night
until like 5:00 in the morning and we
came up with a plan this is what we need
to do to get to number one in 2011 whom
ngah daro bought Eleven Madison Park and
the restaurant began to slowly climb the
list until 2017 when it was named best
restaurant in the world a title they'd
hold for just one year how badly do you
want it back now you know I think there
are bigger things
let's be honest very few people are able
to ever experience Eleven Madison Park
okay and this shouldn't be only limited
for just people who can afford to eat
here and so I think our motivation is to
affect a lot more people on their
restaurant group
make it nice now has five permanent
restaurants including made nights which
has fast casual dining
it's the kind of place we'll Ghidorah
expected to be a part of when he first
came to Eleven Madison Park more than a
decade ago I didn't want to be here
really I didn't want to be in fine
dining and so I was only gonna be here
for a year and then I was gonna go work
at Shake Shack and then I got to know
him and so a year later when it was time
to change jobs I had fallen back in love
with what was always supposed to be my
my life's work and it's because of him
and so it's 13 years later they love
food they love each other I love the
idea they want to make things more
accessible for everyone
I think the world of them you know what
Shake Shack could have been number one I
love the fact that they came up with a
plan to be number one yeah I made it
back